turn now to the latest on the upcoming
supreme court nomination president biden
is talking about potential nominees with
republican senators including minority
leader mitch mcconnell and mr biden says
he does want the advice of senators
along with their consent echoing
language in the constitution cbs news
has confirmed that former democratic
senator doug jones will help guide the
president's choice through the
confirmation process let's go now to
nancy cordes who's at the white house
nancy i'm sure those senators are going
to be very happy to give the president
their advice they will and this is a
process we're learning tony that the
president wants to see move pretty
rapidly urging senators to get his pick
confirmed within 40 days of her
nomination now that's doable but it is
an ambitious timeline and everything
would have to go right for democrats to
make it happen
this is not a static issue it flows back
and forth hoping to head off any
problems president biden met tuesday
with the top democrat and top republican
on the senate judiciary committee and
vowed to seek advice from both sides
before choosing a supreme court nominee
selecting the justice is one of the
president's most
serious responsibilities but several
republicans including texas senator ted
cruz are slamming the president's
campaign promise to nominate the first
black female justice he's saying if
you're a white guy
tough luck at least a dozen women are
currently under consideration they
include federal judges state supreme
court justices professors and civil
rights lawyers several are former public
defenders or prosecutors black women are
what six percent of the u.s population
he's saying to 94 percent of americans i
don't give a damn about you i don't buy
that argument alberto gonzalez was
attorney general to former president
george w bush i know president bush was
very interested in appointing hispanic
when
senator cruz says
that it's an insult to black women
you would say
i don't think they're going to be
insulted
no more insulted the the women were when
ronald reagan considered sandra day
o'connor to put on the supreme court
part of the challenge for democrats who
want to move quickly is that they have a
very fragile 50-seat majority in the
senate where even one absence can force
a delay of a tough vote
just yesterday the office of met new
mexico senator ben ray lujan announced
that he had suffered a stroke they say
he is expected to make a full recovery
though it's unclear right now when lujan
will be able to return to washington
nate
nancy thank you